the
concept of opting out and this is part
of what
the nfl and the nfl players association
inevitably is currently discussing and
they need to get it worked out sooner
rather than later on thursday players
are going to be talking about these
issues at some point a deal needs to be
done between the league and the union or
you can't have training camp and maybe
in this deadline driven sport
they take it right up to july 28
before they have an agreement but one
facet of this agreement must be
that players retain the right to tap out
if they decide they don't feel safe in
any environment
their locker room
practice
field
game whatever the case may be
now i think the nfl will probably push
for
a speak now or forever hold your peace
approach where before the start of
training camp
you have to say you're in or you're out
i haven't heard that
but it wouldn't surprise me if the
league
doesn't push for that
that seems to be an obvious position the
nfl would want we want to know at the
outset who's in who's out i don't think
that's good enough because for the
players who are showing up on july 28th
they don't know what to expect they
don't know what it's going to look like
they don't know how it's going to feel
do you really want a guy who is on the
team in the locker room on the field who
develops a realistic fear
a realistic distress and concern
over the way things are being handled if
he doesn't feel safe in that environment
why are you requiring him to stay in
that environment so i think that players
need to have the power
at any time this season whenever they
see fit to say
i'm out
and then i think they need to have a
period of time after that
where they can say
i'm back in i don't think it should be a
revolving door
where you can say i'm out on october 10
i'm back in on october 17. i'm out again
on october 31 i'll let you know if i'm
coming back before thanksgiving
there needs to be
a procedure that's fair
and maybe you only get
one
leave and return
and then if you leave the second time
you can't come back these are all things
that need to be hammered out
and
it's unavoidable
and let's be realistic i don't want to
be cynical here i want to be realistic
based upon what i've learned over the
past 20 years of covering the sport
i feel like
some players may be tempted
to use the opportunity to opt out
as a way to maybe
get a better contract
for reasons unrelated to the coronavirus
now
let me say this
there could be a player who says you
know what i feel like i'm underpaid i'm
going to threaten to not play this year
even though i have a contract and i
can't hold out because i'd be fine 50
000 a day and i'd have other penalties
if i hold out i i give up my salary i
tap out
i i don't play because of the
coronavirus and if they want me to play
well they better they better you know
give me what i want financially and then
i will not exercise my right to tap out
but there will be some players
who look at this as a financial
proposition
how much is enough to get you to assume
that risk see there's been talk about
the players possibly taking less this
year
give backs under the
salaries that are paid out to the
players that bubbled up a few weeks ago
via nfl media i think it was kind of a
trial balloon that was being floated to
see how the fans would react see how the
union would react
look if i'm a player
and i'm fully cognizant of the risks
that i already am assuming in a normal
year and now
in 2020
i'm gonna have this additional stress
this additional burden this additional
risk that i'm going to be made ill that
i'm going to expose my family members to
illness and potentially to death
depending upon their risk factors
i'm tempted to say you should pay me
more
to do this
you should eat into your profit margin
to do this because you owner of the team
will not be taking these same risks you
owner of the team will all times be
protected by whatever
device you have created to seclude
yourself from everyone else
just staying home
being in a box that is fully and
completely ventilated with no one else
in there on game day i don't know how
many owners even go to the stadium on
game day the bottom line is the risks
are fundamentally different
and so
if you do create a system that allows
players to opt out
the reality is you introduce a new
factor for negotiation to get players to
not opt out
and you've got two categories the player
who
legitimately looks at this and says
for
1.5 million dollars this year it's not
worth it
if you want to
make it more worth it
i'll consider it
but all things considered here with all
the factors balancing
given what you're paying me
i'd rather not play
oh
you're paying me more than what i'm due
to make well now it's starting to
balance out
and then at some point you tip the scale
in the direction of the guy saying i'll
do it that's that's that's reality
and the other reality is there will be
guys who aren't worried about the virus
at all but see it as an opportunity with
the consultation of their agents who i
guarantee you will be thinking through
these issues
and will give us every reason to be as
cynical as we can be about this there
will be agents
who tell a guy hey look i know you don't
care about the virus but maybe you
should well what do you mean i don't
care about i'm not worried about it i'm
healthy i'm young
we're living with me who are at risk
maybe you should maybe you want to think
this through a little bit more there
before you make a final decision
maybe maybe there's a way
that we can play this
to get you a better contract to get you
an extension to get you whatever look at
chris jones right
chris jones can say i'm not comfortable
playing this year under the franchise
tag given the risks of playing i'm a big
guy i don't know his bmi is but anybody
with a bmi of over 30
is in a position where there's a
heightened risk and if you've ever seen
one of those bmi charts
there's a lot of people who are
in the upper 20s and 30s who you
wouldn't think are that high on the on
the overall scale
but
it it
that to me is a very real factor in
these negotiations and that's what takes
it from the negotiations between the
players
and the league collectively and makes it
an individualized thing that can just go
off the rails you could have a rash of
players you could have a stampede of
players who are saying
i'm not playing this year unless you
give me more whether it's because
they want more to offset the risk of
playing in a pandemic or they just want
more because they want more anyway and
they could care less about the risk they
just see this as an opportunity to get
more
it's a fascinating dynamic and it's
another reason why
no matter how hard i try to make myself
optimistic about this i look at these
issues i look at this circumstance i pay
close attention to the news and i like
rodney harrison on yesterday's pftpm
like bill cower in comments he made to
ed bouchette of the athletic i just
don't know
how they're gonna pull this off
and i feel like the attitude in the
approach is
let's just see how it goes
and i feel like that
attitude
that strategy
is not a winning strategy
not that there's a better one
but the nfl had the benefit of a
significant head start here
and i don't know that the nfl has made
full use of its head start
and i'm not surprised we say it all the
time the nfl is not proactive the nfl is
reactive and i think we're going to see
a lot of reacting
in july and august and the problem is
when it's time to react when it's time
to pivot to plan b plan c plan d plan e
plan f
part of what we're going to hear is well
that plan would have worked
if that would have been plan a
and because we didn't
plan for that
from march and just assumed plan a would
work plan b plan c plan d plan whatever
isn't going to be feasible isn't going
to be practical and the primary example
there is the bubble concept there's no
way in hell they're going to throw a
bubble together on the fly
so could we see the same thing we've
seen from other sports
maybe it does get postponed maybe we do
have a late february super bowl maybe we
have a march april or may super bowl and
then when in the hell do you start the
next season
a lot of questions a lot of issues a lot
of basis for realistic concern and not a
lot of information
allowing anyone who pays attention to
the sport on a regular basis to come to
the conclusion
that they have a plan that will work
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports